>>> WELCF NEIO
STATE WEEK,ORIDATESIGS R 15
CY ANY EMPFOST.
A ROMERO
ON ALL OF TH.
>> Repr: WHEN WE LK AT ALL
OFTE
STD
TIONANAW AND OKLAHOMA  CALLETHH
VOITO TOWING LIST JTH AND RNGRA
FLA NONPROFITO
DEFENDDUCTIVEE>>E
D
POSSILG AN AOF COMMISSIO D
MANY HOURS AND SO MUTHAT
AND WE WON SOMETHING.
>> Repr:UGH TOWN OUTTHE WILL OF
LE. RY AND SAD AND
WORRIED.
ITEEE G RD. HIS WEEK GOVERNOR
WITHOUT EXEMPTIONS FORAPE,
REPRESENT THECKING.
SIICT PROTEC
CTED IN THIS
ION.
DAYS BEFORE
N INILL THATS PERFORMINGN ABOR
OF CAEMERGENCY.
>> WE WANT OKLSTE E
COUNY.
WE W IAT O Reporter: ALSO THIS E
KENTUCKY'S OVEO  E GOVERNOR'S
SO FAR 1
PR 15 BAINING O ABORTION.ARIZONN
WEEKS OFRE
NORALEGISLESE
RIGHTS OF E   OF THEIR OWN.
MARYLAND --
ARME OF
RICTIVE ABORTIOACTIONS WE'VE S
,
LAWSUIT TO THE S0 YEARN EVEN
THGHS E DU
OEE VEOL WE CK.
ST A THEORETIC RISK.
>> Reporte WTESENT
REWRITING THEIAB LAW
ALNT TO THARGUMENTS ONMISSISPP
BE THEE BACK AND STAND SUS  RorH
SENG
ROSS COURYDIER
BAINST THE
SL AS TH
FO BAN
>>NK ARETHAT
LA>>, YO
OWUT THIS FURTHEFOR
NOT SURPRISED.
I IN
CHANGED.HE COUN F SUPREMCOURT
ESENT THE FEELINGS
ALL OF US KNOW SOMEBODY AND LOD
AND TE THEDDEN FILLEDBE
PEOPLE NAVIGATN
ATSOME OF THESE LAWS SURE.SO YOE
THG  PVEOR AO PPES
PEOPLE TAY AND FORCEEL WOMEN'S V
CLINICS IN WES ANDLIN
TEXAS INDIAN ALREADYEEN
OPOM TEXAS
ITHE COUNTRY
E  ACCESS TO
SA IN MIND THE
AN SHOUL HAV A PION
IT AEDM ND ALMOSOFPEOPLE WL SO
IN LIFETE.
THIS IS AN I
NNS OFOMD OUR  SAFET
NEFRTO INDIANA, WHATRE
LAT E IONS
THAT.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVHEANMEANS TA
TEXAS IS ALR O
LON MATERNAL MORTALITY
OUTCOMESBEFORE THE STRICTIO OABN
HEPAS REALLY AFFECT MMUNITMUCH
OF
IN PEOPLE'O  GENERALLY IN THEIID
OFENTH
HAS MADEEOAST 50 HE MMUNITIETER
D 'S
E POSI OUTCOMES ABOUCE TO  ABOR
T 50YOHA
OKLAHOM
WHICH HAVE JACTE
BAE ASR CLINICO
CH>> SPET ABORTIONL S
THAT THEO ARE TRNGES ACCESHEMAJ
WE ARETHE WHERE YOSTILL GET CE T
WOH TRAVIN WITH ME ANDS
LYE THHESS THE COUNTRY
EADYNGBY L AND TY